et notre invité ce soir 7 alain souchon
alain souchon après trois ans d'absence
consacrés au cinéma
il nous revient vous n'y revenez alain
souchon en chassant plus gaie avec un
récital substantielle à l'olympia et ce
du 19 au 27 septembre prochain c'est
bien cela alors ce spectacle coïncide
aussi avec elle la sortie d'un nouvel
album et leur le titre de cet album
c'est on avance alors vous avancez à la
sauce nous avons sait où et vers quoi
c'est une chanson quoi on avance voilà
les paroles c'est on avance on avance
faut pas qu'on réfléchisse me compensent
il faut qu'on avance
je suis dans une période de ma vie où où
je le suis plus satisfait de mon sort et
assez heureux de vivre ce que je vis le
succès comme ça les chantiers et faire
du cinéma bon alors j'ai fait une
chanson qui est un peu plus tonique que
ce que je fais d'habitude dans le sujet
quoi l'asie y est pour quelque chose
l'âge le grand âge sûrement et tout y
est pour quelque chose
alors mais maintient une salle que vous
aimez oui c'est une salle que j'aime
beaucoup on avait on m'a donné la
possibilité de choisir à paris et puis
je suis revenu à la loi parce que c'est
un endroit que j'aime beaucoup c'est un
nombre inconnu qui les habite et j'y
suis allé beaucoup quand j'étais petit
enfin bon enfin j'y suis allé beaucoup
quand j'étais petit voir les gens que
j'aime que j'admirais beaucoup quand
j'avais 14 15 ans et je suis vraiment
content du heureux d'y chanter quoi 1 à
3 jours justement d'olympiens ont un
petit peu le trac on a quand même bien
préparé rappelons enfin normalement quoi
on a c'est en fait trop de choses ont
fait on fait de la télévision c'est des
interviews ont fait des tops choses et
en même temps on répète donc c'est assez
suivant mais à combien de chansons sur
c'est aussi très excitant 26 27
et puis toutes les nouvelles avec le
nouvel album enfin sur l'album j'ai une
chanson je chante avec michel jonasz
alors je vais pas la chanter mais
ce en sachant que les autres et alors
vous vous chantez un petit peu comme
comme vous écrivez comme vous parler non
pas du tout quand je vais rentrer sur
scène je suis extrêmement votre acte et
j'ai subi un harcèlement pas du tout
comme quand je discute avec quelqu'un
mais je crois que les gens ils disent
toujours assez marrant tu fais des
contraintes en cellule au secours du
réalisme un petit peu ouais un peu
j'aime bien que ce soit drôle ça des
fois un peu triste quoi c'est un mélange
mais parce qu'on a souvent dit que vous
vous délectez un petit peu la morosité
ben mes chansons ils sont toujours un
petit peu triste elles sont un petit peu
morose sur la forme sur le sur le fond
je veux dire mais sur la forme
sur la forme ces pages crois pas que ce
soit un spectacle en eau du tout c'est
plutôt c'est plutôt à un moment assez
tonique à ses guêtres aux invalides avec
des passages triste parmi centre à nancy
parmi ses chansons il ya il ya une
évocation de john lennon aya ouais enfin
du des années ou ou
on était très très influencé par tout ce
que disait ces gens là à bob dylan nena
de cette espèce dans vie que que les
hommes s'aiment bien que cette envie de
d'amour de communication de trucs qui
avait dans les années 70 que je trouvais
assez émouvant c'est touchant